hey everyone welcome to another hd
tutorial and i'll be showing you how to
get free youtube layouts absolutely free
no copyright problems um this is one of
my favorite websites so i'm definitely
going to do a review on it for you guys
it is called
www.house.net
so pardon the blinking here yt
layouts.net
um they have youtube layouts
three-dimensional layouts abstract
layouts a whole ton of different themes
i'm just going to click on in
a car layout and there's one car layout
so that's exactly what it would be say i
have a tech
techie or a sports a sports layout i
click on it here's this four sports
layout so you can click on whichever one
you want
download it and that will be the layout
for the back of your youtube page so if
i open my youtube page right now
there we go
then obviously you can see this is just
plain blue there's nothing much here and
if you haven't already hit the subscribe
button please do
so um it's just a plain blue background
one of the built-in youtube backgrounds
so now i'm going to show you guys um how
i get a new layout so what i'm going to
do here is click on this one and i like
this layout i think i want to download
it so i'm going to go down here
it will tell you all by the way all the
properties of this layout how tall it is
uh the colors of it the background
actual image
and it says save the background image
and upload it to youtube.com so i'm
going to click on it and it'll say
right here i'm going to save image to
the desktop right
so now it'll create a little icon on my
desktop saying i have actually saved the
image
now i'm going to go back to youtube.com
i'm going to go to my account button
click on it
and i'm going to go to customize
homepage
and here you can i believe change the
background of oh no this is the homepage
when you actually go to youtube.com and
press the home button
i believe i should go to
edit channel so when you go to overview
press edit channel
and here you can change no not here
sorry i'm having here channel design
there's a tab under edit channel called
channel design i press that and it'll
say
that uh here's all the themes that i
have the possibility of using and it
says for advanced design customization
you can choose a file to upload and
there's a maximum size of course so i'm
just going to hit choose file
now of course i go to my desktop and
find that file i'll click on it and hit
open
and youtube will start loading obviously
it's changing my profile theme so wait
one second
and now that i've clicked on i'm going
to refresh the page up here so i hit the
load page button
and hopefully it will be there
so give me one second
well anyway this even if this file does
not work perfectly that is how you
quickly and easily change your youtube
page layout the next time you visit your
youtube page or if anyone else visits
your page it'll be a nice pimped out
layout just from that one tiny little
icon that you downloaded if i go to the
properties it'll say it's just a 246
kilobyte image so it's very small so i
hope you enjoyed this tutorial that is a
quick little way on how to pimp out your
youtube page hope you like it and if you
have any other tutorial ideas for me
just go ahead and subscribe and send me
a message i will guarantee you i'll do
the best i can thanks for watching peace